je m'appelle naël je viens du quartier
de bellevue
thème vers quoi dans la vie n'est pas un
truc qui te plaît s'étaient pas inscrits
à notre prochaine sortie est dommage
c'est pour vous faire découvrir de
nouveaux métiers comme gratter des murs
pourris et padmé pris à bord pour le
travail manuel les mains aussi elles
peuvent être intelligente
bienvenue chez les compagnons je vous
présente tout robert
maire marie
toutes les maisons des compagnons elles
sont dirigées par une mère qui aide un
peu les jeunes au quotidien
un patron qui va embaucher un jeune qui
est formé chez nous c'est un gage de
qualité 7-2 passé assez ap chez les
compagnons vous voyez dans votre truc de
l'excellence ça
[Musique]
tu tires tu qu'à ça je pense qu'elle a
du potentiel pour le former
et vraiment crir que les anciens ok moi
j'suis un compris parce que je rende pas
dans leur cas les 3000 euros vers la
question ne s'imagine bien comment vous
de juger le pull début du derrière
problème avec moi ben si tu es capable
trouvez-moi est entré chez les
compagnons n'est pas du 14 mai évitant
des gens comme elle qu'il faut aider
votre enfant
on croise même je démens vitesse et mes
palmiers toit de la cuisine on est là
pour ça les compagnons pour céder c'est
ce que je reste moi s'ils apprennent je
sais pas si vous réalisez la gravity
lausanne vous essayez nous remonter
moral de nous faire croire qu'on va s'en
sortir qu'on trouve un travail c'est
hypocrite de nous dire ça
si c'est par un simple savent en faire à
transmettre
avant tout c'est vrai je rappelle nos
valeurs un mot fraternité
loyauté
courage
vérité et me lisent et
entonne un jour ce sera tant donné
[Musique]